there's no denying it call of duty war
zone has been a big deal since it
launched back in march of 2020. over the
last year and a half we've watched
warzone dominate the battle royale genre
and stand up to others like fortnite and
apex legends but it was far from a
smooth ride with issues surrounding file
sizes gun meta changes and hundreds of
thousands of hacker accounts warzone has
somehow pulled through but how long can
it stay on top or is it still even on
top this is a state of war zone if you
like call of duty videos like this
remember to like this video and
subscribe to gamespot
[Music]
in early 2020 warzone launched as an
extension to modern warfare from 2019
using the same game engine weapons and
existing maps warzone continued the
story that was set in the campaign and
spec ops mode
at launch the battle royale was a
runaway success unlike blackout call of
duty's first attempt at a battle royale
warzone was free to play at launch
across all platforms and even supported
cross play returning modern warfare fans
and what felt like everyone else jumped
into verdansk and got some oh my god
the hype was undeniable early on as
players began to learn the landscape of
verdansk other players had a timely
advantage that's because infinity ward
cleverly built upon its existing spec
ops map and story and used it all as a
foundation for warzone that meant
players already knew many of the
locations and while verdansk wasn't the
most visually stunning battle royale map
it was a massive area to familiarize
players with at launch the lot even said
it was too big with too many grassy
plains and not enough cover in the
beginning while warzone was solely tied
to modern warfare we saw the launch of
new weapons like the finn lmg the
fennick and more and events like the
haunting of verdansk also began to roll
out complete with spooky operator
bundles and an excellent zombie mode
that didn't take itself too seriously
this also happened to be around the time
the world began closing down for the
2020 global pandemic so while shelter in
place began to roll out war zone gave
millions of people something to do
months after launch war zones seemed to
be firing on all fours gaining attention
from everyone cod fans and even lapsed
battlefield players and with the
seasonal outline for modern warfare
already in place more weapons like the
growl 556 and the bruin continued to
trickle in it was here where we got our
first taste of how just one gun can
shift an entire meta a trend that
continues to this very day whether it be
a game breaking glitch like the as valve
shooting through all cover or weapons
like the car 98 that just couldn't be
beat at long ranges balancing this
increasing number of weapons almost
seemed impossible for better or worse
nearly 30 more weapons were added in all
at once thanks to the integration with
black ops cold war at the end of season
6.
since then the number has continued to
grow with each season bringing in all
sorts of things like melee weapons nail
guns the tec-9 and more unfortunately
while all of this was going on seasonal
updates and events brought the file size
of the game to one of the largest to
date if you wanted the full experience
of modern warfare black ops cold war and
war zone a base ps4 or xbox one wouldn't
cut it and that announcement came
directly from activision
after all this time it's been really
easy to point out warzone's faults
because several of them were large scale
and directly affected how people played
the game at the same time some issues
while not necessarily game breaking
simply felt like a massive lack of
communication to players like the soap
operator bundle quietly added in well
after modern warfare support as well as
other leftover modern warfare weapons
but despite these setbacks warzone has
had some fun highlights too one example
being in-game events like the cold war
announcement which had everyone fleeing
to the stadium to check out the new
trailer and unlock the bay of pig's sks
blueprint others like the end of her
dance brought everyone together to
destroy an armored train learning from
other battle royal games where players
couldn't experience events after being
killed warzone smartly allowed players
to work together to complete the mission
other events like the stadium opening up
for the first time or the zombies
infestation were less fleshed out and
chaotic in my opinion but they usually
led to greater story elements like
verdance getting nuked other things like
the bunkers and train stations had
pretty mixed results and to me felt like
a poor attempt to keep players engaged
during a lull in the greater story
especially when it came to gathering
intel a chore that had players grinding
for story bits for little to no reward
in large part seasonal events were
handled with more care and attention in
other titles like fortnite and apex
legends especially when it came to
introducing new characters and maps
these battle royales also competed with
warzone and player counts and massive
mainstream success but if you needed
your realistic shooter fix warzone was
simply in a league of its own
[Music]
after this year and a half warzone's
future isn't exactly clear especially
because we're on the verge of some big
changes in mid-october warzone
introduced two weapons from vanguard the
stg44 and the m1 grand doing this sends
some mixed signals will we be seeing
vanguard's full arsenal introduced into
warzone the same way as cold wars
if so this could mean weeks of meta
changes and a total gun count of over
130
these vanguard weapons also offered up
to 10 attachments doubling that of the
current guns while this is all possible
to maintain it could be really messy on
a larger scale how long will activision
and raven choose to support warzone
before moving on to something like war
zone 2. personally i think the upcoming
pacific map would be a great place to
start over it would be a clean start for
warzone instead of another integration
but even when i think of these two
options i'm reminded that this will
continue to put a strain on our hard
drives no matter what
if a new war zone is launched players
will struggle to enjoy both on one
console forcing them to pick sides
unless more hard drive space can be
added a conversation we're all tired of
having ah
when you say that it makes me tired with
the launch of war infinity ward and
raven had quite the shoes to fill it
found itself with loads of success with
a massive player base reaching casuals
returning call of duty fans straight
battlefield fans and people who just
didn't care for the look and feel of
fortnite in any event 2022 is shaping up
to be a big year in gaming with some
serious competitors like halo and
battlefield well maybe what is that so
there's a chance that warzone may
eventually fizzle out of popularity so
while the player base may still be high
it might not be the darling fps it once
was lastly ricochet the kernel
anti-cheat system that call of duty
plans to implement with the release of
vanguard will it work if so this could
mean a brighter future for warzone as
hacker accounts have gone from bad to
worse in the last year
while lots of people like myself are
hopeful and supportive of this move
we've seen some startling news that the
program has been leaked and is being
reverse engineered by hackers in reality
reports indicate that activision
actually sent the anti-cheat program to
third parties to test and in the process
it was considered leaked as more testers
gained access
activision definitely has their walls up
at this point but only time will tell if
this attempt to crush cheaters on pc
will work
[Music]
warzone has been a whirlwind of
successes and missteps over the last
year and a half we've seen hundreds of
guns dozens of game modes and millions
of players come and go while we don't
exactly know what the future holds
warzone has definitely made its mark in
the gaming space while it could always
use more improvement i think it's safe
to say that warzone will be with us for
a while don't forget to like this video
if you enjoyed and thanks for watching
[Music]
you